I know my name is Theo I'm 13 years old
and I'm a huge fan of your work I want
to know if you think art is important
and if art is important is it as
important as the sciences Thanks Theo
Theo you got to have art we have to have
art we have to have science I will claim
that science is the best idea humans
have ever had but I mean I'm science
educator I mean you expect that from me
but I listen to music all day I make up
lyrics for songs all day when I make a
thing which I like to do all the time a
tinkerer I like the thing to look good
and I have done stand-up comedy telling
jokes in a hope in an effort to get
people to think about us ourselves our
relationships to each other our society
these to me are all forms of art that I
participate in I shudder to think what
my world be like without other artists
contributing which does not be nearly as
good you have to have both but what I
encourage everybody is you can't you
don't want to have one to the exclusion
of the other
you want to have both science and art
however science has affected our society
dramatically what's the most significant
invention ever
might be a sewer without sewers we would
just not have as good a life as we have
right now in the developed world and
that's based on science roads cars this
computer this video interaction that
we're having that's all enabled by
science but you want the background to
look good wait you want my tie to look
good whoever made my tie was an artist
and I'm glad that he or she was out
there doing this piece of art so you
gotta have both men don't don't take one
or the other and don't use it as an
excuse not to learn algebra